No way I’m not gonna make it.
Right coach?
SCREAMING!
They always told me to follow my dreams.
Maybe that’s something that they say to a lot of kids.
Push-Ups.
I’m too tired.
You the number one player in the area code.
What do you think the haters want my baby to be?
Tired.
My son needs a coach like you.
And he’ll take your team from good to “Oh my God!”
I don’t coach high school kids.
All my kids are 14 youth.
Jace turned 14 yesterday.
These programs are where
the best talent is getting their start.
These are future NBA stars.
No way I’m not gonna make it.
Right coach?
Guess I’ve been worried that everything
I want could be slipping away.
I dropped in the rankings from 1 to 4!
So clap back on the court. You gotta reclaim that crown.
Can’t afford to lose, Coach. Not you. Not me.
Your program is barely holding on financially.
You gonna screw things up like you always do.
My father would tell me that I had to learn
what it is to lose before I learn what it is to win.
Hands up!
For what?! I didn’t do nothing!
On the ground!
He is an eighth-grade honor student.
This feeling you have right now.
That fire.
Use it.
Carry it with you to practice.
Your next game.
Ohhh!!!
If we wanna get to nationals,
we gonna have to win out the tournament.
No more losses.
The longer you wait to redeem yourself,
the harder it becomes.
Sometimes other things in life
feel more important than basketball.
Y’all aren’t just my teammates anymore.
Y’all are my brothers.
No doubt.
People are gonna want you to stand for many things.
More than anything a team stands for each other.
Win or lose you walk on that court with swagger.
You walk off with swagger.
SCREAMING!